you mentioned the matrix
do you think we're living in a
simulation it does
feel like a thought game more than a
real scientific question well i'll tell
you why like i think it's an
interesting thought experiment to see
what you think from a computer science
perspective
it's a good experiment of how difficult
would it be
to create a sufficiently realistic world
that us humans would enjoy
being in it that that's almost like
if we're living in a simulation then i
don't believe that we were put in the
simulation i believe that
it's just physics playing out and we
came out of that
like i don't i don't i don't think so
you think you have to build the universe
yeah i think
the universe itself we can think of that
as a simulation and in fact
what i try sometimes i try to think
about to understand
what it's like for a computer to
start to think about the world i try to
think about the world
um things like quantum mechanics where
it doesn't feel very natural to me at
all
and it really strikes me as i don't
understand this thing that we're living
in
it has there's weird things happening in
it that don't feel natural to me at
all now if you want to call that as the
result of a simulator
okay i'm fine with that but like i don't
know the bugs in the simulation
there's the bugs i mean the interesting
thing about the simulation is that it
might have bugs
i mean that that's the thing that i the
but there wouldn't be bugs for the
people in this simulation they're just
that's just
reality unless you were fair enough to
know that there was a bug
but i i think back to the matrix yeah
the way you put this
i don't think that we live in a
simulation created for us okay i would
say that
i think that's interesting i've actually
never thought about it that way i mean
you the way you asked the question
though is
could you create a world that is enough
for us humans it's an interestingly sort
of self-referential question because
the beings that created the simulation
probably have not created a simulation
that's realistic for them
but we're in the simulation and so it's
realistic for us so
we could create a simulation that is
fine for the
people in the simulation as it were that
would not necessarily be fine for us as
the creators of the simulation
but well you can you can forget i mean
when you go into the
if you play video games in virtual
reality you can
if with some suspension of disbelief or
whatever
uh it becomes a world it becomes the
world even like in brief moments
you forget that another world exists i
mean that's what like good stories do
they pull you in
and the question is is it possible to
pull you know
our brains are limited is it possible to
pull the brain in to where we actually
stay in that world longer and longer and
longer and longer
and like not only that but we don't want
to leave
and so especially this is the key thing
about the
developing brain is if we journey into
that world early on in life
often how would you even know yeah yeah
so i i
but like from a video game design
perspective from a west world
perspective it's
i think i think it's an important thing
for even
uh computer scientists to think about
because it's clear that video games are
getting much better
and virtual reality although it's been
ups and downs just like artificial
intelligence it feels
like virtual reality will be here in a
very impressive form if we were to fast
forward 100 years into the future
in a way that might change society
fundamentally like
if i were to i'm very limited in
predicting the future as all of us are
but if i were to try to predict
like in which way i'd be surprised to
see the world
100 years from now it'd be
that or impressed it'd be that we're all
no longer living in this physical world
that we're all living in a virtual world
you really need to be calculating god by
sawyer it's a
he'll read it in a night it's a very
easy read but it's uh
assuming you're that kind of reader but
it's a it's a good story
and it's kind of about this but not in a
way that it appears
and i uh really enjoyed
the thought experiment um i think it's
pretty sure it's robert sawyer but
anyway he's he's
apparently canadian's top science
fiction writer which is why this story
mostly takes place in toronto
uh but it's a it's a very good uh it's a
very good sort of
story that sort of imagines this very
different
kind of simulation hypothesis sort of
thing from say
um the egg for example you know you know
i'm talking about the short story
um by the guy who did the martian
who wrote the martian you know matt
damon
no the book so we had this whole
discussion
that michael doesn't uh doesn't partake
in this exercise of reading
he doesn't seem to like it which seems
very strange to me concerning how much
he has to read
i read all the time i used to read 10
books every week when i was a
when i was in sixth grade or whatever i
was a lot of science fiction a lot of it
a lot of history but i i love to read
but anyway you should recalculating god
i think you'll
you'll it's very easy read like i said i
think you'll
enjoy sort of the ideas that it presents
yeah i think the
the thought experiment is quite
interesting um
one thing i've noticed about people
growing up now i mean we talked about
social media but
video games is a much bigger bigger and
bigger and bigger part of their lives
and then and the video games have become
much more realistic i think
it's possible that the three of us
are not uh maybe the two of you are not
familiar exactly with the numbers we're
talking about here
the number of people it's bigger than
movies right it's it's
it's huge i used to do a lot of the
narrative computational narrative stuff
i understand that economists can
actually see the impact of video games
on the labor market that there are there
there's fewer young men of a certain age
participating in like paying jobs than
you'd expect and and that they trace it
back to video games i mean the problem
with star trek
was not warp drive or teleportation
it was the holodeck like if you have the
holodeck
that's it that's it you go in the
holodeck you never come out i mean
it just never made once i saw that i
thought okay well
so this is the end of humanity as we
know it right they've invented the
holiday
because that feels like the singularity
not some agi or whatever
it's some possibility to go into another
world
that can be artificially made better
than this one
and slowing it down so you live forever
or speeding it up so you appear to live
forever or
making the decision of when to die and
then
most of us will just be old people on
the porch yelling at the kids these days
in their virtual reality
[Music]
but they won't hear us because they've
got headphones on
you